genug gelacht neues von bernd hocke
thüringens ministerpräsident der herzen
hat jetzt diese woche cdu und fdp
angeboten seiner afd könnte eine
konservative minderheitsregierung in der
afro tolerieren damit merken sie
versucht der bern staatspolitische
verantwortung und bürgerlichkeit zu
simulieren wer s glaubt tatsächlich
bricht das menschenbild seiner partei ja
immer wieder unkontrolliert durch
zuletzt als in nürnberg eine 17-jährige
in deutschland geborene deutsche mit
teilweise indischen wurzeln zum
nürnberger christkind gewählt wurde
binningen darm und sie ein top
christkind wirklich aber für teile der
afg offensichtlich nicht blond genug da
fragt man sich schon bis dem rollschuh
bei einer youtube
hallo ich bin stinksauer
dieses mädchen hat mein lebenstraum
zerstört einmal nürnberger christkind
sein
vielen dank bin ich nahm und sie mein
kostüm kann ich jetzt wegschmeißen und
ich bin nicht der einzige der stinksauer
ist der afg kreisverband münchen land
hat das hier bei facebook gepostet
nürnberg hat ein neues christkind eines
tages wird es uns wie den indianern
gehen ach ja
dafür muss man die afb einfach liegen
sie sind zu doof ihren rassismus auch
nur für drei minuten zu unterdrücken
frau moon sieht in nürnberg geboren
katholisch ministrantin spielt mehrere
instrumente und fußball
kurz gesagt die ist deutscher als heiler
afd
diese selbsternannten retter des
abendlandes haben null ahnung vom
christentum das christkind kommt in der
weihnachtsgeschichte überhaupt nicht vor
das haben sich im sechzehnten
jahrhundert protestanten ausgedacht also
gar keine richtigen christen
da fällt mir ein wussten sie eigentlich
dass die adventskalender abgeschafft
wurden ja hab der brandner von der afg
jetzt rausgefunden
die müssen ab sofort geschenke lager
heißen wegen der verdammten muslime aber
wie so oft hat das leben zwei seiten
dreht man das produkt um steht da ganz
christlich adventskalender nur im
twitter post von stefan brandner bleibt
das thema ohne die zweite seite
einseitig und zwar absichtlich das war
einfach der versuch mal mit ganz wenigen
mitteln große aufmerksamkeit zu
erreichen das ist schon genial und super
erfolg super erfolg wenn man absichtlich
liegt ist es okay traurig in deutschland
werden schon wieder geschenke in lager
gebracht so und jetzt kommen mal drei
wahrheiten über weihnachten die viele
fdp-anhänger schockieren werden erstens
viele historiker sagen es gibt ernst zu
nehmen die indizien dafür
dass jesus eltern juden waren zwei einer
der heiligen drei könige kam nicht aus
nürnberg ich sag nicht welcher und
drittens forensiker der uni manchester
haben rekonstruiert wie jesus
wahrscheinlich ausgesehen hat
olivfarbene hat dunkles er krauses haar
mit anderen worten jesus so ungefähr
aussehen
sade und frohes fest allen echten
christen ja ist denn youtube
[Applaus]
michael de schreibt auf facebook wilke
du bist der letzte arsch nur große
fresse ich möchte ich mal sehen wenn es
hart auf hart kommt dann schaust du dir
in die hose warte ab ein sprichwort sagt
man trifft sich immer zweimal im leben
mach weiter so mit einer großen fresse
wie können warten
sehr geehrter herr b man sieht sich im
leben nicht nur zweimal sondern jeden
freitag um 22.30 in zwei oder hier auf
youtube wenn sie uns abonnieren